this is such a great moment already I
think that we can make it even better
you were regaling us with some of the
songs that you created God are you buddy
but would you guys be up for creating
some original boy band songs tonight
always you kidding me yes to the green
screen haha here we are now my favorite
thing about boy bands are the songs so I
thought you guys make the experts in
creating some new boy band songs that
don't currently exist we're gonna put
you guys to the test in a game we like
to call boy band okie really great very
powerful I went on the internet and ask
you guys for title suggestions you set
me some great ones so you guys will be
competing in a round-robin back and
forth singing what you think the song
should be based on the title makes sense
yeah sesame okay James Corden you're up
first
okay okay here we go your song is
popcorn on the futon okay let's get some
music going
P to the O to the P to the cor and
that's right gonna say it again I got
popcorn on my futon just you listen up
baby you ain't never wrong hey I can
take this way over okay missing you my
baby some of my corn is party I ain't
gonna sing baby bear okay okay go let's
go go okay you can compete you an NSYNC
how can you compete come on here we go
Lance oh this is huge your song is
called do steps into my heart who steps
into my heart oh hey go oh oh here I got
two steps in my heart and I got it just
for you hahaha I'm bringing it to you oh
okay okay okay okay okay
James your song is strawberry cream
cheese strawberry cream cheese Oh
I'm a chick baby I didn't know how to
say please
for your strawberry cream cheese I'm
begging you please get for my strawberry
cream cheese whoa okay okay bring the
noise bus hello Lance your song is om
GGG oh yeah Felix that's bass on them
okay gotta like your smile and I like
your touch you make me feel
oMG Gigi watch on my couch I let you
down real nice and slow
I'm gonna make it go oMG gggg there's no
way he's gay
there's no way he's gay my high school
self is screaming right now here we go
your last song is retweet my heart BAE
it's very topical oh man
ah
[Music]
mocking see you on Twitter but you don't
stop and I need you to read switch my
heart babe see you and Twitter you're
trending again you're not Facebook and
you are not my friend
ha ha ha oh yeah sure I got the bag drop
all right Mike doesn't matter drop okay
Lance your last song is called why
didn't you reply to my texts three years
ago alright for this one I'm gonna need
something hold on hold on hang on a
second
oh no way no way he's going full bunk
oh girl I met you four years ago then I
saw you again one year later but there
hey why girl didn't you text me back
three years ago yes you're writing you
can watch it here I good oh good you
guys thank you for something wrong ask
for Eve and days huh you guys that was
so impressive I think music was the
winner tonight I'm yeah yes I think
music and ears and all of it